what's up everyone we are back at tony
robbins unleash the power within in
chicago i'm with my boy grant kellogg
now what's up man what's up brother
great to see you man thanks for coming
on the show
Thank You grant and I met what was that
two years ago at hero-city at Draper
University thanks to Jeana close yes
thank you Gina and her epicness of
working with Robbins Research
International and then we got to hang
out and then we got to hang out more at
the we got to hang out at UPW in one of
the didn't we at either Palm Beach or at
did we not or I don't think this is the
first UVW were connecting yeah oh my
gosh is the first you're right it is
okay so grant so this is what happened
after like two years ago when we first
met I've just been watching Grant going
and living a life of kind of nomadic
life it's it's been very nomadic he's
like you're you're either in Bali or
you're in Miami
pretty much yeah like that's what like
those are like the cities and and I and
this is gonna be an episode kind of on
like what it's like to be this kind of
like digital nomad of today's a day and
I'd like I want to pluck your brain I
want you to teach other people about
kind of what that's been like because
you're not only your are you learning a
lot about like the Bali people Balinese
Balinese people and their culture art
history music language food all this
stuff but you're also learning what it's
like to be an entrepreneur and build up
a client base and you know your your
your building your building like
wireframes for apps for different
companies and you're doing you know word
of mouth and you're using sketch as a
design tool and stuff
so let's unpack this so you're
Minnetonka right and from Minnetonka
talking I like that yeah repin from
Minnetonka Minnesota I you know I love
where I'm from Jennifer hearts Hudson
tonight was performing you know here at
UPW and she was saying like she lives in
Chicago there's no place like home and
for me I'm a proud Minnesotan and our
sports teams are turning around
so it's a it's a great time to be from
Minnesota our boy grants from Minnesota
and as you guys know I was in Minnesota
for like two and a half years as well
from 17 to 19 so we definitely got some
vibes there um so what was this kind of
moment for you where you figured out
that you wanted to embark on going and
seeing other places in the world and
living there and challenging yourself
with that I've always been very
open-minded and in my house as a kid we
had this little spinny globe and almost
like every night growing up I would go
and spin it and I just put my finger on
a different country or a different city
or a village and and I would just dream
and visualize of going to all of these
magical places and then getting myself
going to Draper University and being
only one of the few American
entrepreneurs on in the superhero you
know University in Silicon Valley it
really opened my mind and my heart to
other cultures and languages and ways to
live and ways to eat and ways to read
and ways to talk and ways to think and
ways to love and it just really inspired
me and I wanted to go and see what life
was like in other people's shoes and
plates and in cars and everything like
that so you said something really
important there which is that your mind
was expanded to all these new cultures
and ways to live but we're human across
the planet but we do human in slightly
different ways we do the air and the
food and the water and the shelter thing
very similarly but we do the love and
the art and the music in the language
and that stuff very differently and so
it was interesting that being in the
Draper ecosystem you were able to see
that and then most people are usually
starting companies as they leave you
know you chose to you know start your
own as well but you didn't like go and
get funding and stay in Silicon Valley
and build a team you decided to go to
where did you go first and how did you
know that you were gonna be using like
just design tools like sketch
to help people build
they're apps and what they're developing
how did you how did you kind of like
piece all those things together that's a
great question I mean I've been very
nomadic for the last like two three
years first I started traveling around
the States road-tripping you know at
during the time a lot of my friends from
high school and things like that we're
still in college so I'd go in and crash
at their colleges but this last winter I
came to a breaking point where I I said
you know I need to expand and I need to
see new things and I I'm ready for a
breakthrough I'm ready for for change
and and so I started and I just booked
the ticket to London and you know a year
later I never looked back and found
myself flying back from to America from
from Bali and so first was London so
this is mmv
summer okay in 2015 16 17 year doing the
US yep driving Draper was 2016 okay so
okay so Draper was 2016 then 2017 was a
lot of this u.s. exploration nomadic and
then you bought a ticket at the end of
that year exact so it's been this has
been like nine months now yeah okay so
now these last these last couple of
months that you've been doing this so
okay so you're you went to London and
then from London you stayed there for a
while yeah I when I started traveling
you know I was I was so travel happy
that I wanted I've started I one week I
went to London the next week I went to
Paris and I went to Amsterdam then I
find myself in Barcelona and a terrorist
attack happened and everything came into
perspective my life was almost taken the
terrorist attack happened right outside
of my hotel room and many young kids and
people lost their life that day and
commute can we talk about this please
please okay so whoa whoa is right yeah
what was right it whoa
it it really it really opened me up
and what was the what was the attack
what would it would happen so a person
took his car and ran it and into people
on the sidewalks which is something that
goes on in Europe and and was this based
on religion or was based on heat of
other sort do we know they they said the
the attack was related with Isis
okay so potentially Islamic terrorism
and then the that's what they said that
the attack was related to that and there
were was there like a dozen people
killed or injured there was about 18
people that lost their life that day
teen lost their life that was it was
about I believe it's 18 but is it
something and in Barcelona and this is
your hotel you're staying at is on the
same street yep exactly it could have
been on the street yeah I could have and
it was it was really bizarre because I
was supposed to be on this street i
right before the attack I went and got
in an acai bowl and I met this amazing
woman that owned this acai bowl place
and we were having a very long you know
intimate by the way acai bowls our
grants favorite he's just a little bit
of humor and chillage yeah and this
crazy story but grant [ __ ] blows his
eyesight people yeah so we want to
connect with me let's go get a smoothie
Bowl acai bowl I would I would love that
but you know you know my love for us ie
both started when that bowl changed my
life because I went into that shop and I
was supposed to go back to Las Ramblas
the the big tourist area in Barcelona
right by Barcelona to Beach shoutout to
Spain I love you Spain an amazing
country shout out to Spain has been
there too I'm very grateful to have been
to Spain I love that place it's magical
yeah and so this amazing woman
you know she guided me to go to the
beach when I was gonna go check out all
these you know tourist streets and
everything and ended up at the beach and
everyone's screaming and crying and I
speak a little bit of Spanish I mean I
understand poquito see but not enough to
when people are frantic and
in that type of vocabulary the context
of things that were happening and also
didn't have a SIM card so people were
contacting me and I wasn't able to get
back to anyone unfortunately and you
know all of a sudden I found out what
happened and there was so much
uncertainty with an you were in your
hotel room no I was on the beach you
were on the beach so but it was on the
street of where your hotel is exactly
less than a mile less than a mile away
do you yep
holy cow yeah that's crazy and so that
also pressed like a kind of a wasn't a
reset bone it was more like a
perspective shift button for you because
in for me too if I'm there less than a
mile away and I'm trying to be a nomad
and enjoying another place in the world
and all of a sudden there's Europe which
has been known for a couple of these
attacks related to religion that that
definitely messes with your perspective
it's like damn am i safe mm-hmm my life
safe yeah and it's a crazy crazy crazy
feeling you know having your life be at
risk like that and you know I send love
to all the souls that requires that you
know that carried on that day and you
know I I it happened and we didn't know
if there's an they were gonna come to
the beach or what was gonna happen next
we didn't know and the only thing I
could do is talk to God and whatever
that is for you love the universe
yourself it lies within and I remember
looking up at the clouds that day and
that that moment and I asked God you
know like why not me I said are they
gonna come in are they gonna get me am I
gonna die today just let me know if it
happens anyway and he said no child you
have more time to play more time to play
and to impact others hopefully and your
grow yourself and and live and enjoy
these moments and you know after after
that I spent a the next week
I read the The Alchemist I checked
myself into a nice spa and wrote a lot
really went internal
and you know realize it's all about the
journey in the process and to be
grateful for every single day in every
single moment even when things are tough
even things are hard even when you want
to be down just find that positive
because it is we're alive we're
experiencing this human experience and
it's such a blessing to be here we owe
so much to life leo so much to humanity
life doesn't owe us anything nobody owes
us anything you know this is such a
privilege to be able to even speak on
your you know on your channel and your
show and to be alive today the privilege
that people built this equipment that
enables us to do this and built the
internet infrastructure and all this
other stuff that we just are a bunch of
black boxes to us in terms of how they
work and yeah that we're both alive on
this rock that randomly evolved in the
cosmos we're very grateful yeah
grant you you're you're very you're very
very interesting so ok so we go from we
go from Spain then in a lot of internal
time a lot of inter a lot of internal
time and then you're starting your your
your continuing your business at the
same time yeah ok so you know this is
none this is no incorporation or
anything this is just independent
contracting yeah right
so people are sending you a couple
hundred couple thousand bucks you're
sending them back assets that they need
in order to to build out their apps or
designs that they need right on and then
that's is that kind of taking off right
around this time the word-of-mouth
spreading yeah it was it definitely was
but after this experience I I took a
little bit of time off and I and that
was okay
and you know coming from you know
Silicon Valley was just go go go okay
which is great which is great it's let's
create for this world but I there I I
realize you know it's okay to you know
to show it Tim Ferriss and do the 4-hour
workweek take a day off or go on
vacation or go visit your grandma yeah
or work your ass off you know whatever
whatever is
is whatever your heart feels follow that
follow that internal that internal light
that that divine message from above and
channel that and and run with that and
so after you know after I went through
that another level of a spiritual
awakening which I'm coming to awareness
that the spiritual way awakenings never
never end once I was able to get back
into my feet thanks to some amazing
friends that hosted me in Italy in
Florence Italy shadows my brother Andrea
there I was able to get back into my
into my craft and into and to start
working with entrepreneurs again and it
was it was it was amazing
it was amazing yeah and so then from
Spain to Italy getting back in the craft
it's good you took some time inward and
then from Italy was it to Bali from
Italy I went to Greece and I I connected
with my long my uncle that I haven't
seen I connected with my like second
grandma she's not blood but she's like
my grandmother there in in monastiraki
in Athens and they showed me around
Greece for about four four or five weeks
it was amazing it's one of my favorite
countries in the world now I went on a
writer's retreat there with my great
friend electro Mustaine and I you know
went into you know Santorini drove ATVs
around there did my work in Athens and
ate a lot of Greek salads and tzatziki
and euros and man Greek food is amazing
how's this as your as you're going and
traveling from London to Spain to Greece
Italy where you staying with friends is
because how do how does one do the
nomadic thing when you don't have
friends in those locations do you when
you land are you trying to go to meetups
and events and be like hey like I don't
know anyone I'm trying to make friends
and then like if you're a good person
then maybe people will invite you to let
them let you crash on their couch that
kind of stuff totally I think it's all
about building
tribe and for me it's it's my love for
traveling I've found how important it is
to build an international tribe and I've
been so grateful to be able to go to
Draper University and be part of the
Tony Robbins crew environment which is a
global network and and when I'm moving
around through this existence I I I'm
conscious of connecting with people all
around the world so that I can learn
from them and I can share and take bits
and pieces from every single different
person because every person I meet is is
my teacher
likewise yeah yeah and then it's really
important to also actually get their
contact info a lot of people will just
engage with somebody for whatever ten
twenty minutes and then you won't get
their contact info but then you'll never
be able to say hi to them when you visit
Turkey or when he was in South Africa
wherever they're from yep
they've got to get their contact info
and then be able to reach out and feel
totally free and not anxious when you're
in that process most definitely and I
mean of course with the social media
platforms that we have today it's it's
really easy to connect with people I
mean you could go to Madrid and go on
Madrid Spain on Instagram the location
and just start liking pictures and maybe
somebody will connect with you that way
but the best you know the best
connection is just going out there into
the Meetup into the yoga studio into the
beach and you know just just letting
people know hey I'm new hey you like you
know show me around and then you can
maybe link up with those friends that
even build international community with
and maybe you can crash on their couch
Thank You mo they can teach you about
the culture all that cool stuff so okay
so after Greece was Bali yep okay so now
when you get to when you get to Bali the
cost is lower than Europe yeah much yeah
it can cost up to like 70 bucks a day to
live in Europe probably and it costs
closer to 20 bucks a day you were
teaching me to live in Bali yeah yes
somewhere in that range and of course it
depends on the lifestyle that you want
to live but as a you know as a lean
entrepreneur digital nomad someone
that's running a startup Bali is an
amazing place Southeast Asia in general
I am you know Thailand is also an
amazing option but for me Bali is a
great spot just in terms of the the
global community the love on the island
the Balinese hospitality the amazing
exotic fruits all of the example yoga
studios the the just the energy on the
island the gratitude on the island the
karma on the island the positive karma
on the island and the surfing the waves
are incredible it's just like a climate
screen the climates great coconuts are
like $1.00 everywhere you go smoothie
bowls are on point it's just it's just a
phenomenal phenomenal place to be able
to like work on your business as also
while discovering what you know maybe
what business you want to start next or
what you can implement in your business
I've got to ask this because I think a
lot of people are very attached to the
this visual of what it's like to be on a
beach this experience we're very
attached to this sipping on a coconut
relaxing on the beach and then the funny
thing is when you get there and you're
there for months on end you're like damn
I need to go back because I need to go
and get some meaning and purpose to my
life because I need to go and continue
building something into the world
because you can't just relax on a beach
and find that to be the most meaningful
thing in the world
you got a nought for every single person
I guess somebody could find ultimate
meaning or purpose in doing that but a
majority of people find meaning or
purpose and actually building something
that impacts the world longer than
themselves
and so this is just a funny story that
so many people think that like going to
the beach and being there forever so
amazing but really it's kind of nice in
like spurts you go to Bali for a bit
do that for two weeks four weeks
whatever it might be and then you come
back and you hustle then you maybe go
back and relax six months later or
whatever I feel like that's been a flow
that I've been learning from people that
they've been following that has been a
little bit more healthy for them what do
you think about that I think that that
can be great and you know the digital
nomads traveling the whole world
constantly isn't for everyone it's it's
really hard you know some nights you'll
wake up in a in a party hostel and the
next night you might wake up and mansion
in Italy and that's just how life goes
it when you put yourself out there it
might cry because you're like you're not
in a stable home for some people they
need a stable home and totally yeah and
that's what the additional no matter
you're bouncing around you you really
have to learn how to ground yourself
grounding foods to eat like sweet
potatoes and mashed potatoes and things
that are warm and filling blankets and
jacuzzis and just getting somewhere and
meditating or doing your practicing yoga
like really grounding in each and every
way because when you when you're on the
go you know even if it's just in
domestically like you can just pop here
pop here pop here but let's be here now
damn that was actually really important
didn't even think about how if you are
doing digital Nomad life it's even more
important to do grounding exercises
everything from even a blanket can make
you feel more warmer or Jacuzzi like you
were saying or just meditating on being
in that place in the world and feeling
your feet dig into the soil they're in
that place that these are feelings of
being grounded and then it kind of
washes away the anxiety more that's so
interesting that's crucial for digital
nomads yeah it is it really is yeah it's
a it's an incredible lifestyle warm
foods warm drinks all that some nice hot
cacao or chocolate or tea yeah it would
really serve you on the road
but you know for me I I make sure I pack
different things like hemp seeds and
chia seeds and and macadamia nuts and
almonds
we love macadamia oh yes and pick cow
and MCT oil and brain octane oil and b12
I'm good I eat plant-based so you know
you're traveling in different villages
or different airports or countries and
cultures and you know they don't always
have Whole Foods products you know vegan
gluten-free plant-based so it's it's you
got to stay on the road but also
limiting the digital nomad lifestyle you
you you learn minimalism because there's
two things we got to unpack there okay
quick quick unpack if your plant-based
Arthur like amazing non plant-based
foods that you want to eat like do you
at least taste them you know you know
yes and so so as a as I've been I've
been plant-based for about two years now
and I have I don't know what everyone
had call it a mistake or a mess-up or
whatever I have eaten cheese and I had I
had bread meat in Korea I was in Seoul
South Korea and you know growing up I
always heard about Korean barbecues
gotta try the Korean be be cute gotta
try the Korean be be Q so I did you know
but I'm all about conscious eating and
plant-based diet and that is what I
preach but I also you know think it's
important to experience cultures the way
they are but the amazing thing about
vegetables and plants is that you can
take these flavors of cheeseburgers of
steaks of chicken of tuna of salmon of
feta cheese of mozzarella the list goes
on and on and make your plan base and
you can make it plant-based that's true
there's a lot of new companies that have
emerged that I tried this plant-based
feta cheese it was [ __ ] amazing I've
just tried so many plant-based meats now
I'm really digging them possible burger
is really great it's really good you
know I mentor at indie bio and it's a
large biotech accelerator in the world
and
we're really close friends with them and
they are working on they have so many
companies that are working on
plant-based and not even just
plant-based but on top of that clean
meat so they're taking cells from fish
cells from cow cells from pigs cells
from chicken and growing it which is
actually really effective because then
you can take it into these massive just
like you brew beer you can start brewing
chicken and brewing cow and it just
makes it so much more effective and it's
it's very exciting in that sense okay
and then there was another thing that
you mentioned after the food that I
wanted to touch on what was it what else
did you mention after after the food
when you were talking about Bali and I
went in and went into chia seeds and
hemp seeds and then you know something
else keep going it'll come back okay
yeah most definitely um but like like we
were you know we were talking you know
the the plant plant-based and did you
don't know my lifestyle like it's not
not for everybody I think it's for in
terms of like lifestyle and diet and
business and everything it's like what
works for you what makes you happy
what's gonna when you wake up in the
morning what's gonna be that driving
force that you're gonna say yes I get to
do this today yes this is who I get to
be yes this is who I am
yes this is I am proud that these are my
values and these are the people that I'm
around and this is what I'm working for
and this is what I'm creating and this
is the message that I'm sharing and you
know having that having that purpose and
and having it be filled by it by passion
and I'm honored and completely so
blessed that I I've been able to to
pursue my passions and it's it's just
it's it's a wonderful life so wonderful
life do you think there's a
you're saying digital nomads at this
lifestyle is not for everybody
the this for people these people that do
like you that their mind is expanded to
all these different cultures is there a
way that you can you know impact the
world with what you're gaining like can
you teach people in the United States
about what's going on in Bali in some
relatable way that maybe teaches people
in the u.s. some new practices for
sustainability or philosophy or ethics
or something interesting like that a new
way to look at science maybe even is
there something that Bali can take from
the u.s. there a way for you to distill
what you've learned the u.s. to the
Balinese people mmm that's a that's a
that's a great question and what I
realized being around the world is no
matter your religion or skin color or
culture we're all brothers and sisters
and we're all in the same planet right
now we all are here together and
sometimes you know bali or the Middle
East or Africa or all these places can
seem so far but all you can do is hop on
a flight you're there you know the
planet is is pretty it's pretty small it
only takes 40 days to sail around the
earth that's like that's nothing less
after the show let's get it we got one
more day UPW with after that will it's a
small planet yeah most definitely but
you know I think what what we're waking
up to is is humans is you know
sustainability and people in America are
becoming aware of it people in Southeast
Asia are becoming aware of it just
plastic use plastic is a huge thing in
Bali everyone used as bamboo straws and
biodegradable yeah exactly
bamboo is used for so many different
things use bamboo plates yeah exactly so
I think it's just you know being
resourceful because when you're living
on an island you're really able to see
you're swimming in the ocean you're
surfing you're able to
the plastic there you know being in a
big North American continent it can it
can sometimes be hard just garbage is
going to landfills which is way out of
your perception exactly but when things
are right there in front of you it
smacks you in the face and it wakes you
up so do you need to go to Bali to or
any you know anywhere it's a two bo
realizes not necessarily but to answer
your question there are many ways to
share these messages of different what
people are doing around the world to
advance humanity and technology and
spirituality and consciousness and
sustainability and health and wealth and
you know like I said the list goes on
and on but we just have to share we have
to share what we've experienced and not
hold things in you know just speak from
the heart rather than from the head and
just let it flow and and don't be afraid
to just to just share what you know
share what you know God you know share
what you know you made it pretty clear
that the whole like we are one mentality
we always talk about the you know the
importance of you know 7 1/2 billion
people all being the brothers and
sisters and embodying that mentality and
understanding that when we do focus on
sharing and loving and caring for each
other and for this planet together that
we will prosper better that way
a lot of the time though people come
back and say that well what about you
know geopolitical leadership what about
this this really important understanding
that if you know if you're not the ones
that are leading the world then at any
point somebody else can just come with a
gun pointed at your head and say give me
all of your land give me all your food
give me all your tools give me
everything and then you're screwed
because you're not the one that was a
leader somebody else came and screwed
you and so it's like this whole process
of meditation spirituality these cleese
cleansing processes that then make you
feel like you never want to grab a gun
and go and threaten somebody with
violence so that you can take from them
so that we can build technological
systems that enable us to have food and
water and clean energy and cleans
shelter and all these different things
that give us these basic needs and
hopefully one day you having something
like you wanting to go to the moon does
not prevent me from going to the moon
and it costs so little that anybody can
go to the moon anytime they want and we
have such abundance and energy that you
know I've been using these analogies to
try and explain to people what a
potential everybody so scared of the
word utopia and and I'm not I'm not
really scared of it I actually strive to
become a pinnacle of a civilization what
it could potentially be and I think
there's a good balance between private
interests of like our company needs to
compete with this company in order to
make the best thing so we can make the
most money and continue making the most
research and development and impact of
versus the like just you know sitting
back and relaxing in Italy or Bali or
wherever as well it's a very complicated
puzzle but I've you can you can tell
that there's been a lot of the we are
one versus the geopolitical leadership
conversations that we've had on the show
where do you sit in that puzzle you've
obviously sit in the we are one but like
do you also realize that you know you're
in the you know full do you fully
realize that you're in like the u.s. the
world's leading economy with the world's
leading technology and that we do funnel
so much of our taxpayer dollars into the
military and that's because we care so
much about retaining global leadership
so at any point Russia or China or
anybody else can't just come and say
like fork over your West Coast and we're
gonna start coming in through the east
or whatever yeah you know I am I'm
nowhere near an expert in terms of
politics and and and you know global
leadership but what I can say is from my
experience traveling I am proud to be an
American and I am beyond grateful that I
have an American passport and I am
beyond grateful that I am an American
citizen no matter where we stand today
I am I'm a proud American hell yeah yeah
hell yeah hell yeah it's amazing pretty
beautiful beautiful country that we live
in and we have it pretty damn good here
no matter what's going on we have it
pretty damn good
but not to not to speak down on any of
the things that are happening I think
there are so many big problems that we
do need to tackle um so I want to make
there are other beautiful places in the
world that are doing 100% overall this
is a beautiful this is a beautiful
planet and and I see I I see and I hope
that more more countries and more people
and more cultures around the world can
come together as one and inside each
others as brothers and sisters and I
want to go through and minoo want to see
you done democratically though you know
I want to see it done without massive
oppression and force and without music
festivals and body paint and yoga and
and rap music and you know like like
yeah so funny you can do all those
things right you can you can have as
many parties and yogic festivities as
you'd like and those things might
actually drive people closer together
but you know war and weaponry and
violence and greed and corruption will
drive people apart and mm-hmm
we have we've had many conversations
about that on the show so I'm it's good
that you are very grateful for being a
United States citizen and knowing about
even though you do carry I think a lot
of people that classify themselves as
liberals or people on the left of the
political spectrum in the u.s. at least
care a lot about the we are one
mentality but they sometimes don't carry
the the true blessing of what it is to
be a United States citizen in this world
as well so I think combining those two
things together like you have right now
is very important I think many of us
actually that watch can say that like
you're grateful to be a u.s. citizen and
you also think that it would be great if
the world work
together moving forward but also you
don't continue to compete and innovate
but also work together move we're doing
a pretty decent job okay grant how about
a other crucial kind of takeaways you've
went from Bali jugo better to Miami back
to Bali side kind of how it's been now
two minutes to Minneapolis back and then
so it's a bit of the loop and I'm
getting getting ready this fall again to
start exploring more parts of the world
I'm not gonna let you guys know where
yet Paula grant on Instagram you have to
follow me on instagram to stay up with
harvest link in the bio it'll be there
but just just getting ready to you know
explore more of the world and spread
more love around the world and got a
blog Roland III don't have a blog I
would love to see a couple videos yeah
definitely
you can take what you're already doing
it grants and serve AM stories are
really good you can just take those and
just throw them into a YouTube video you
just need to throw them into premier
stitch them together and then export
that as a video to YouTube and now
you'll have a two minute three minute
video of your last weekend wherever you
are and it's good that way you can keep
a log as well that's longer than
Instagram I've been helping people with
this kind of [ __ ] for a while so I love
I'm recommending that one to people and
people that take the advice on that when
they feel like like it adds it adds a
new [ __ ] to do to your list and you're
trying to like relax when you're abroad
I know but at the same time it leaves a
log and like that's really cool and I
think a lot of people will see it and
get inspired by it as well and realize
that crap like there's that interesting
thing about Italy or but Bali or about
wherever you are
okay so somewhere else is coming up in
the fall that's good
not now you guys know I'm friends with
you is these these brilliant ideas but
thank you for for motivating me and
inspiring me to to push out even more
content and you know you can even start
with basic and I'm gonna be launching
some more drone drone aerial hell yeah
all the beautiful places I go and you
know I just just hope that you all
explore the world you know what they say
at Draper explore the world
- enthusiasm and yes failing failing
again until you succeed and stay
grateful stay grateful and stay you and
be true to yourself it's so difficult to
actually dig in to find that within
oneself
I think meditation has helped a lot with
that process definitely and I think
travel can help a lot with that as well
yeah there is a tremendous amount of
wisdom that comes from exploring the
cultures of the planet is there another
takeaway because you've been like maybe
we talked just a quick bit about you
know the business as well so it's been a
lot of word-of-mouth so like you know
you're you're you're making design
assets for companies and the then you
know you can ask them hey like do you
guys know to other people that you can
recommend to come and come to me for
design and so that's a way that you can
continue growing your your business your
ecosystem in that sense so the just the
just this idea that you can get work
digitally and then you can send the
digital work back it's just the gig
economy it's very interesting so do you
want to maybe speak on that and kind of
where you're at with that now and will
you ever bring in another person to help
you grow the business is that ever what
it would be like or are you will capping
the work so that you can you know set
your be focused on your travels and
blogging in that sense totally yeah so I
I right now the the freelance work is is
something that is is driving me to
pursue yoga meditation and personal
coaching and so it's it's a it's a it's
a tool it's a resource for me to
identify who I truly am and my purpose
in the world and with a laptop with the
cellphone with the camera with the
microphone you know you you can start a
blog you can start a YouTube channel you
can do freelance work you can do this
and that
and it doesn't mean you need to do that
for the rest of your life or even build
the team to do it but you can use these
these skills to design that life you
want to live or make that you know
$50,000 to then fund that into your
channel or whatever it is so for me what
I'm what I've been personally doing is
is doing freelance work to be able to
explore the world and do that what I
love so I can continue to self discover
myself but when I have been traveling
what I've discovered is that I'm a yogi
and I love yoga and I love the practice
of peeling away the layers like you were
saying every single day peeling away the
layers to your true self and that daily
practice has helped me you know expands
and be grounded and and really love
myself and give give me it gives me
purpose and so I've come to the
realization that I want to share yoga
and meditation and adventure and surfing
the retreats and through immersive epic
experiences and I had my first retreat
in Bali in March and it's crazy how
designing app started and it brought me
into hosting and holding space for
people from all around the world to come
and learn about themselves and eat
amazing plant-based cuisine and chill on
the beach would show on the pool and go
surfing and do yoga and hike volcanoes
and sing songs and dance and eat
chocolate and and and love themselves
and love each other and so dance but
it's it's it's brought me to the way
you're talking about it's just so
beautiful visioning and visioning what
it's like to be there with you and is
this a retreat center that you kind of
you know partnered with for like
short-term whelmed work of helping them
out with running this no man so I you
know from Tim Draper I learn you know
fail but like fail fast and so I I
haven't partnered with the retreat
center or anything I just I went through
my being in were attending or teaching
or oh yeah I was teaching and hosting
and I
to the retreat nor did the retreat yep
yeah yeah okay so you started it and
then you advertise it to people hey fly
to Bali I'm gonna host this retreat
exactly and it was right after I became
a certified yoga instructor and it was
something that I always wanted to do how
many people do get to come out ten
people that's pretty good Malaysia
that's pretty New York City people from
India people from London Chicago Chicago
myself Minnesota it was a you know super
like global tribe and you guys did all
those cool things that you listed and
you were organizing at all yeah yeah
with with with the co-hosts and yeah
who's an amazing retreat host as well it
sent the acts of Yogi I'm gonna keep
doing these yeah yeah across different
places across the world and then oh
interesting so you're gonna do so you're
gonna go and explore the different place
in the world for a bit and then host a
retreat there once you get your feet dip
your toes in it and exactly cool the
culture the market is right the timing
is right the location is right well sign
us up yeah
sinus and that this actually might be
good ideas where your own footage that
you're taking where you end up posting
all this content it might be good to
also post the post it all on to the site
and not only on a YouTube but on the
site and then that's where you can
organize the different gatherings across
the world retreats and show photos of
the previous ones all this kind of cool
stuff a video of the previous one I like
that most people I don't think I've ever
heard of a retreat center that's mobile
yet cool yeah so the retreat I guess
Robins does is the treats are mobile cuz
he goes the different place in the world
and that does his retreat there which is
interesting you're kind of following a
similar structure with I love how Tony
has gotten into hospitality with it as
well and real estate with owning you
know yes properties in Fiji and having
people come and stay at his retreat you
know or at his his his resorts and
there's all these places around the
world that I
love to have homes in real estate and
assets and be able to bring people into
these sacred spaces in beautiful
energetic places vortexes of the world
to come and transform and break through
and so that's a big grand Cal equation
yeah I like that yeah it's good good
vision it is thank you I think it'll be
amazing life I'm glad we got to your
vision man yeah we got there and we've
got there yes good helping me bring it
out you're so welcome
I love this is this is why I'm just very
grateful to have this as something that
I do because you know when when somebody
gets the ability to come from right here
and out and through and like it they
feel like oh that's it that's yeah
that's me that's what I want you know
that makes me feel fantastic and I think
that's why we're both here too yeah
because we both know that when 10,000
people at the same time can have that
feeling that energy is just it's
unparalleled right now there's almost
nothing in the world that's that's quite
like it so to be a part of this together
is really great and I like the vision a
lot and hopefully we can help one
another with the vision we'll be growing
the media arm of what we're doing
showcasing all these brilliant
scientists entrepreneurs technologists
educators and and then they'll need
places to go to these vortexes of the
world do retreats we can maybe get some
you know some some grant do you know I
do have a brand yet for what you want to
call yeah launching real soon well put
the link in the bio when it's live for
that and you know simulation can strike
up a cool little partnership as well
where we can send people that way and so
yeah as we grow we'd love for you guys
to funnel to these different vortexes
and come on these retreats so awesome it
sounds like that's a good strategy
that's a good this has been really good
the digital nomad life is fascinating
their udders there was a moment for you
of let you know pulling the trigger
going doing it seeing that life can be
cut short um in different places in the
world so it's important to kind of be on
our toes to make sure that life doesn't
get cut short sometimes and that then
that you were able to pull together a
business you gain skill sets that were
able to run a sustainable business while
at the same time exploring yourself
through yoga meditation acai bowls
across the world and you know that's
been your digital nomadic life and now
like you're onward to you did your first
retreat and you're gonna be doing more
soon with this new brand that will link
and bio it up any other thoughts on the
way out grant just go for it
just jump go for it you know I mean
imagine yourself on the last day of your
life and and look back into this present
moment what would you what would you
wish you would have done and whatever
that is just go do it right now
like exit out of the video right now
thank you for tuning in but go do it
like it's it's there's there's really no
time to waste the only the only moments
that we have is exactly right now and
the past is only a memory the future
it's coming but the future is now let's
create it so it's been a pleasure being
on this this show and I hope that
there's been some value for you guys and
I appreciate you you know this
mastermind brain picking session has
been really fun and it's it's helped me
you know clear my mind and get my
thoughts out and be able to come from a
heart place so I really appreciate it
and I'm looking hope that I can come on
the show again I love this guy
okay so you know what I you know what I
really liked about that last parts that
there is only now and you only get now
and then now and it keeps coming but
seize that moment carpe diem seize that
moment and go and take whatever that
essence is within you and bring it out
into the world whatever that may be so
like you said exit and go do that thing
I love it
awesome this has been a pleasure grant
we got grants links in the BIOS if you
guys had a good time definitely go
follow grant go and share some of this
cool digital pneumatic wisdom with other
people go tell to people about have them
tell to people let's go share it out
comment below with your thoughts
subscribe join us also join us on
patreon we're trying to sustain this and
continue growing and impacting more
people so do join us on patreon and will
become an actress soon with a couple
more interviews in the chat town area so
much love